hi those who have been following me now
for some time you'll know that i'm an
obama student
and follow cytosensei those that um
don't know me he was a ninth dan and i
sensei
asked him to be a caretaker of his dojo
when
he since he passed away and he done that
for the rest of his life and has now
passed on
so i try to make these uh films
mainly because of lockdown in the
winters
in the past few years i've i've written
two books
but uh with the lockdown and
not having the freedom that we've had
we're not for ourselves anyhow
we i decided to make some short
films for for the people out there who
are still interested in
learning about aikido
if i say the word iwama or
aikikai tamiki style yoshinkan style
you know people think that i'm having a
go and saying
iwan who's best i'm not trying to say
that even if it's coming across this way
and the reason i'm not trying to say
that is because i see a lot of iran
teachers out there that i don't agree
with
and why don't i agree with them because
like me
they're an individual we've all taken
something
from psychosensi but as a person
our own personality has decided to
change it
or the way our eyes saw it we
we thought we saw it a certain way
what i'm trying to do in these uh films
are
to give you whatever style you're you're
doing
uh an insight into my head the way i saw
what cytoscenes he taught me
i i followed other styles for ten years
i become a second man in other stars
some wanted me to become fourth when i
met cytosensei
he gave me my first dan it showed how
far
away i was from really having a good
you know solid style in my body
that worked against his own personal
uk's the students that he bought for me
when he traveled the world i had no
chance of moving them
they were like boulders heavier than you
could imagine
when they gripped you the sweat would
pour out of you just trying to move
from the grip of the wrist
i wanted to i was fascinated and i
wanted to know
what they had that i hadn't got because
i thought i was one of the best
in the uk at the time when i was doing
aikido
when i started in 1973 like you know
wasn't
you know very big in the uk
and uh i was trying to go to a seminar
every month
and trained with all different people of
all different styles
it was quite brutal because i think we
were fighting more than learning an
art training with psychosensity for many
years
he decided as he got older to slow
things down
i've said in other films that i really
didn't enjoy that
why because it brings out all the faults
you start seeing
all your imperfections all the things
that you want to hide
all the things that you don't want
yourself to see
let alone other people your partners
your training with
but it does it stares you in the face
and you have to
face it eventually if you're a
perfectionist
many people get so many different things
out of aikido
that i cannot even cover what they get
out of it
but i i am seeing a lot
of all different styles of aikido
what i call flowing stars uh
definitely non-marshal
they're starting to because of lockdown
they're having to do individual
solo practice so i'm going to try today
to show you
how we can do individual practice
combined with the weapons now
to me the reason i followed such a sense
is because
his weapons and body techniques
made sense he used to say
when doing weapons think of taijitsu and
when doing taijitsu
think of weapons
i now understand it many years on what
he's talking about
so how do we harmonize
we harmonise and we learn by going slow
those of you who watch bruce lee and
he's kung fu
the most one of the most amazing people
ever
in my lifetime but
then you see exactly the same style done
by an old tai chi master
in very slow motion so
as we've got older i'm getting slower
because i'm looking at the detail so
this is a gift to you
if you want to take it to say
in your own space in your own home you
can do it slowly
i've dressed up today in my clothes i've
got my watch on i've got my jeans on
you can do aikido anywhere i see some
people
some teachers putting on a ghee to teach
you
that's fine if that's what they think
that it is that's a responsibility
of the etiquette of the art
you could say the japanese names or you
don't have to
if you're not japanese saito sensei said
to me once
when i apologized sensei i don't speak
japanese
he said well why would you your english
that to me confirmed that we say it
through respect
the japanese words we don't have to say
them
okay so like
i have me what means the same arm so if
i place my right arm out
and my partner grips with their right
hand my wrist
and i turn it over
like this
i'm going backwards because i'm drawing
the person
now where can that one come from let's
have a look
after the cut on the seventh february
you turn your body
and ski
after the cut you turn your body in ski
we must think of aikido from head to toe
and if you can make it operate
completely
so i'll go back so you can see the feet
as well
so i'm coming down with the cut
opening as i turn opening the foot
it's all a thought process if my hands
are moving
so is my foot i shift the weight
as you would in tai chi a slow movement
a nice ski
of course this is done
quickly
i'm trying to show you the heel is up
i come down with the cut the heel is
down
i open on all the foot as i turn
and i ski
now if it was on the sheer nagging
it's the same as the coming down
with the cut as you
take that can it's coming around to the
right you press that can down
ski press that can down
ski
press their ken down
tank back foot
then we start to add movement instead of
turning on the back
foot we make the back foot go offline
and float it so you have you can have
floating feet
it's very difficult to learn this if you
do enough weapons you will learn
how to transfer
weight
how to transfer weight how to create
mass mass from your center
mass from yahara tandem
japanese words or not japanese words
float off line of your attacker mass
so that we don't stop the technique
mouths take up over your head bow
release this it looks like the arm is
doing it but in sheer naggy
the arm shouldn't do it it should be
following your partner down
so take it down up over your head
over your head bowel release
this is all obtained through swinging
the can
if you swing the can
you build mass and at the bottom of the
stroke you squeeze
your hands both hands like ringing a
towel out of water
and the small fingers they
operate and the others don't operate so
much
so you squeeze
squeeze hey
all right okay
don't have tension in the body just
swing the can
i see so many stars
where yes
it has power but look i'm using
my hands i i might be
using a
i'm using the power that i use in the
obama weapons
but this is all wrists and arms
there's a lot of um people in the world
doing kashima
bokkeum these are fighting skills
of swordsmanship the obama ken
is ikiken the spirit of the can
it's nothing to do with swordsmanship
other people may tell you differently
what i'm saying
is nothing to do with swordsmanship
it's about
lending blending
grounding blending
with the sheer nagi and the weapons you
learn
to get off the line so the person can
pass you by
psychosensity would say
dorzo it means please
i'm not in your way i do not wish to
restrict you
i hope you found this of interest i will
be going through
different techniques trying to show you
where the weapons come in
a lot of people say about irimanagi
is like the hasso gush of the joe
in the twenty joseph murray and they're
right you take it
up and you come down
but the thing is your remy
is entrance to the rear
it's an entrance to the rear
okay so thank you for watching
i appreciate all the people that give
time to this
whatever style you're doing please train
slowly
cytosense is no longer here you can't
i'm not trying to sell him as the
teacher
i'm trying to sell you better i could
have
so that you understand if you have a ken
in your hand
and you're going to move it it must move
from thought
to movement from thought
to movement the feet
are operated
the feet are operated
it becomes a joyous move
you know you you're up here
you can do a few dynamic ones just to
give you that
what i call young person's buzz or to
release your
key your coke you okay
it's all about hey
hey ah when the
foot lands
and the heel lands
so it go it's your whole body that's
doing it thank you for watching
i'll see you soon